[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM MELENDEZ: Hi, I'm Tom, a
software engineer at Google.
This is the first video in
our series Using Ansible
with Google Cloud Platform.
We can use many available
Ansible models to manage
the various services in GCP.
Dylan is here from
Ansible to tell
us more about how
a DevOps team can
take advantage of these features
available in the engine.
DYLAN SILVA: Ansible is
a YAML-based language
that can perfectly describe
entire infrastructures
in Ansible playbooks.
It is also the engine that
executes these playbooks.
This execution is performed over
SSH or WinRM without an agent.
Currently, there are
over 1,000 plus modules
that enable these tasks.
TOM MELENDEZ: And the
amount of user contributions
is impressive.
DYLAN SILVA: Yeah, we have
over 2,500 unique contributors
at this current time,
over 22,000 stars,
and 7,000 plus forks on GitHub.
We even have Ansible books
written by community members
as well.
Over the years,
we've seen Ansible
do some pretty unique things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM MELENDEZ: In these
next few episodes,
we're going to talk about
how we used Ansible to manage
a satellite imaging system.
We can even send commands to
the satellite via our Ansible
playbook.
Ansible is quite
a powerful tool.
In this video series, we'll
talk about how you can use it
in launching instances,
deploying across region load
balancer, and configuring
customized networks.
We'll even discuss how to
build a custom network.
DYLAN SILVA: All right.
So let's talk a little bit more
about that Ansible controlling
a satellite thing you've
got going on there.
TOM MELENDEZ: Sure.
The satellite imaging
system consists
of three subsystems,
commanding, image processing,
and end-user applications.
DYLAN SILVA: So commanding,
you mean Ansible is actually
working to control
the actual satellite
and have the satellite
do some functions, right?
TOM MELENDEZ: Yes.
As satellites orbit
the Earth, they
go in and out of remote
ground station coverage.
It's ideal to place ground
stations near the poles
so they will have
more opportunities
to communicate with satellites.
In our series, we use Ansible
to launch some instances,
run an executable on
some camera parameters,
and then call a
custom module to send
those parameters to the RGS.
DYLAN SILVA: OK.
So tell me about
image processing now.
TOM MELENDEZ: Well,
image processing
is a sensitive issue.
Basically, images that come
directly from the satellite
are not ready for human use.
There is a custom processing
that needs to occur.
In this series, we talk about
building custom networks
for both the image processing
system and the remote ground
station.
DYLAN SILVA: And
end-user applications
allow the user to see
the processed images?
TOM MELENDEZ: Correct.
DYLAN SILVA: I would
expect these images
to be quite large, right?
And you probably have
customers all over the world.
How do you keep the
response time low
and the experience good?
TOM MELENDEZ: Well, we
use the cross region load
balancer functionality built
in to GCP to ensure users
are getting directed to
the closest data center.
We'll also cover how to
set this up with Ansible.
DYLAN SILVA: Very cool.
And you mentioned
the custom module.
We at Ansible take a
lot of pride in fact
that Ansible is extensible
enough for you to do that.
TOM MELENDEZ: Agreed.
To update our remote
ground station,
we built a custom module.
We can't go over that
module in detail,
but we can show the
audience how to build
their own modules for
either internal use
or to be open sourced.
DYLAN SILVA: So that
being said, let's be
sure to cover documentation and
some best practices, too, OK?
We want to hold community-built
modules to the same standards
as our own delivered modules.
TOM MELENDEZ: Got it.
DYLAN SILVA: I'm looking
forward to talking about Ansible
and Google Cloud together, Tom.
TOM MELENDEZ: Me too.
And don't forget to check out
all of our Ansible modules
at the URL in the
description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]